[Musik]
ihr wolltet es unbedingt meine damen und
herren von herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einer neuen episode sandra und
lukas hilf mir gott hilf mir besondere
alle folge ich war jedes mal werbung für
mich weil ich bin ehrgeizig was ist das
eigentlich im juni den newcomer an der
ipad ängste ab 50 cent alter beste die
ziehen jetzt meine ganze feuchtigkeit
immer eine bedienung an sich der richtig
gut heute gehen die länder aber gut
meine damen und herren heute soll es
nicht um schwachsinn oder podcast themen
oder keine ahnung was von mir geben
sondern würdigen scheiß schweinehalter
[Musik]
spielt direkt wieder in köln
150 sind wirklich cool und die werden
nicht mögen glaubt mir ach sowas
eigentlich gar keine angst zu haben
ich glaub ich bin macht wollen dass die
aber wie die ausgespähten daten und hier
ist es interessiert mich auch mal also
er stellt gleich den eltern seine
freundin vor
ok
wenn die sachen angezogen alltag der
monarch einmal keine anfrage von hilfe
willkommen ob wir mal die therapeuten
nachweisen können was sagen bei youtube
bringt gar nichts wieder 100% 80
gestresst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also gut sachen hier erzählt sich weg
war ja doch ganz so volksnah freundin
hab ich mir selbst gekauft zum 21
hier wird seine freundin kaufen lässt
jetzt im ernst zum plastikding ihr was
du plastikding das ist meine freundin
wird doch dass ich eine freundin
ich glaube dass so etwas habe ich schon
verkehrt gemacht
laster in ruhe oase gummipuppe das ist
meine freundin du musst dir auch mal die
beschreibung durch lesen ja das über
beide ohren verliebt seine auserwählte
samantha ist die perfekte frau martina
zugibt ist
dabei hilft ihr bei euch dieses sachen
sich außerdem die christen preis von mir
wirklich sein hat kreativ alte hatte ich
kann es nicht glauben ich habe mich so
für dich gefreut bist du nicht manns
genug dass man richtig hinzukriegen
mittlerweile legendären pferdeschwanz
gesehen haben erstmals 30 einen habe
jetzt habe ich ein und jetzt ist es
nicht
haben ja auch gesehen und er solle doch
alba zimmer mit dem gebäude haben gerade
ich würde lieber doch mein handy hat als
sich als die perfekte freundin isla de
also nochmal ca eigentlich würde und
meine videos sind
du denkst das ist einfach so eine
partnerbörse man kann sich im plastik
pop samantha nicht mehr vorstellen kann
ich jetzt da nicht mit rein nehmen das
heißt ich musste ich jetzt leider hinten
verstecken chur
es wird wieder ein langer tag vorbei zu
gucken
ich werde dich vermissen du hast echt
nett mir jungen 1
also bisher steht das video wirklich für
mich aus fremdschämen und für dich aus
ich will den typen haben wieder gastein
augenmaske da noch mal wieder zu spät
das ist ist das nicht sein vater
arbeitet er da auch oder als doch noch
eine menge arbeit zu erledigen
die türen müssen heute noch zu ende
bekommen sie immer dabei und überall
[Musik]
alles auf mich zurück hast du dir mal
gedanken darüber gemacht
wenn du hier scheiße baut ich habe
gesagt wenn ich das zugleich die sache
ist nun alle leid ihnen so ein bisschen
ja mein erbe locker nur so sein leben
leben so mit einer gummipuppe blabla
wieder darauf steht ok kommen soll er
machen ich meinen sohn er würde ich auch
sagen hey das ist das richtige
das ist ja er sorgt sich ob wohl aber
erst erkennt das nicht ja und ja ich
weiss nicht ja also sein vater ist ja ja
ja ja an versteht alle seiten ein
bisschen es tut mir echt leid dass es so
lange auf mich warten musste
das problem ist micaela hat mich schon
wieder überstunden aufgebrummt
aber ich glaube gott der zieht die sogar
aus das ding ist ja muss auch mal
überlegen es ist jetzt nicht so dass er
irgendwie nur sich denkt hey ja bla bla
das ist hier meine gummipuppe und ich
weiß es ist eine gummipuppe sondern er
denkt er wirklich dass sie auch lebendig
irgendwo irgendwie menschlich ist
stetig
jetzt hat er gesehen hat schon immer so
was wird dann so loos der ist doch der
ist doch mit einem menschen
[Musik]
es ist arbeitszeit was machst du hier im
auto ja ich habe etwas weg gebracht aber
bist du eigentlich von einem guten
geistern verlassen
das schiff hat dich gesehen ja sex zu
liegen
das gefährt bin du daheim ausgezogen ist
vermutlich deine bude dass ich den
ganzen kram bezahlen kann ich meinen job
verlieren der vater macht sich sorgen um
seine existenz durch dieses komische
hobby seines sohnes soll den kündigung
galt der soll zu hause bleiben ist dir
das klar jan hast du wieder antun
eigentlich will ich dass das so ärger
bekommst wirklich die seine güte ich
weil ich ich hatte sexy aber es kommt
nicht wieder vor wirklich ich verspreche
dir was hab ich richtig gehört hören der
looser in der werkstatt
das mädchen will ich mal sehen ich weiß
gar nicht dass es nur wenn er denkt dass
es ein richtiges mädchen oh mein gott ok
dazu das spannend wussten die frau
gehabt kennenlernen erwartest die drei
mal auf cloud ich wollte unbedingt mit
mir schlafen ich habe ja gesagt dass das
nicht geht aber die cover zufällig dann
auch bei der arbeit also verständlich
doch irgendwie beizukommen ist bei jedem
so ist bei mir auch die zwischenzeit ich
komme einfach dann leute hier natürlich
völlig normal gelegen hat sollte man hat
schon nutzen oder nutzen ja völliger
ernst dass man etwas das man stimmt bei
denen ich dass muslime
man hat ja noch so kleine socken an com
reports
also ich meine schlussendlich klar jeder
kann ihn sein hobby ausleben ja grün und
blau aber es ist ja auch völlig
selbstverständlich dass andere leute das
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch finden
es ist ja auch jetzt nicht so vorgesehen
von der natur dass er mit einem stück
gummi ist vom 28
okay die mutter klopse doppelt meine
mutter svetlana mal sowas erwischen wie
du mit gummi frau rumpf nötig wäre hier
erwartest du besucht das ist ja alles
kennt dich nicht so an wie ich es soll
ja ist das nicht auf dem tisch inhalt
geschminkt was man kann da ja zwei leute
und schnellste jahren mache ich möglich
aber die talaat gewicht ordnung das
lenkrad kommt danke wir bis dann
ich freue mich so für ihren freund hilfe
macht hatte sachen und dann ist es
plötzlich vorbei
ich werde sehen was der vater saß aber
naja freude das erfahrt ihr dann
wahrscheinlich in der nächsten folge
genau wenn es dann ein teil vier von
luca und samaria geht auf hilf mir geben
soll dann lasst auf jeden fall einen
daumen hoch unter dem video jeder sandra
deine maske kann es jetzt langsam ab
machen
klasse an junge die cutv nehmen seit
einer halben stunde auf was achten rat
dachten den thema 25 mal wahnsinnig nein
sondern inhalte video gefallen hat wie
bereits gesagt dass gerade ein daumen
hoch unter die video da schreibt uns
geld unten in die kommentare um sandra
jetzt besser oder schlechter aus als
vorher natürlich die geister aus ganz
deutschland
ich muss jetzt ein baby päuschen machen
genau abonniert gerne meinen kanal und
schreibt uns auch in die kommt nochmal
wir auf hilfe reagieren sollen
[Musik]